the hammer here back on the rich I
wasn't sure how you been Hank I couldn't
let you down rich uh maybe we can buy
some beds to go with those pillows
that's been part of your history here
man
all right so go for it Hank what's your
what's your thoughts on the Breeders Cup
this weekend well there's 12 races
tomorrow so and for today I won't go
through all 12 because we wouldn't have
time for that obviously but let's talk
about the classic it's like a national
holiday for me tomorrow but anyway
there's a lot of speed in the classic
the horse to beat is probably going to
be gunrunner who's a very hot streak a
ton of speed arrogant who's past
champion is in a one-hole Mike Smith's
gonna have to gun him an arrogant is has
not done too well at the Delmar track
has been beaten their last two times
he's run there and some people think he
may have seen his best days I think he
may hit the board someplace but with all
his speed you've got a horse call
collected Baffert has four horses in the
race including West Coast who won the
Travers they're all part of the pace a
horse who I like was going to come off
the pace who has a chance to win at 12
to 1 or better his move Taisha
and Baffert now trains that horse he's
won at the mile and a quarter distance
in the past he's legitimate close where
he has a recent win and he's got trading
van Dijk on it was a good young rider on
the west coast and so I'm gonna take him
on top and gunrunner arrogant and west
coast
and I'm gonna throw in a long shot named
Churchill who is over here from from
Great Britain and I think there's a
super 5 bet or you can take the 6 and
the 5 and play the other 3 underneath
and super fact is and you'll be in
business okay so you take the six horse
say that one
time cuz broccoli Mukai ease there's no
way you would have said that Brockman if
given if given five shots on it new page
now Michaels asked me how to pronounce
it three times so I was calling you for
tips on the breeder Scott we're having
dinner tonight and they're in here for
the game on Sunday he asked me who my
best Breeders Cup horse was in case he
was asked so are you taking him for
stone crabs or it cuz he'd liked he does
like he likes the steak though how's the
steak yeah but Alison stone crab guy
okay so you're going to you taking of
this stone crabs tonight we're all going
chris is going and your publicist and
we've got a nice group fantastic very
good so okay so multi-age you the Rich
Eisen show listeners in Albina are all
on the six horse oh and also the turf
race I like the euros okay and there's a
horse called Ulysses who has been
training up to this race and likes the
firm turf and an Irish spread number
five number three Highland real and
other Irish bread and Chad brown has two
horses in their Beach Patrol number
twelve and fanciful angel box those four
and a superfecta okay so now if you had
one bet to make let's give let's give
our show listeners and viewers hang
Kohlberg's best shot here at making some
cash on the Breeders Cup what do you
have for us Hank hi today I'm gonna bet
paradise woods number seven and the
distaff and use that horse and doubles
with the five horses I like okay in the
classic tomorrow so I guess in that so
then give me your classic best bet then
so you like the six horse and the
classic right I like the six horse at
twelve to one where you could bet it you
can set up to win
I like gunrunner I think gunrunner it's
the two some questions about one of the
gunrunner can make the mile and a
quarter so if ye nails nails omit the
wire so be it and
I think West Coast will run a strong
race that's another Baffert Wars
okay so skipper always gets these horses
ready for races like this so but he
frequently brings in the longshot so
boxed is six to five is what you're
saying
the eight six five eight what eight is
win this I'm gonna throw no there's no
two in there I might throw Churchill
number seven and be a bomb underneath in
the superfecta
okay so you like multi-age gunrunner
Churchill and and wesco and West Coast
West Coast very good what and yeah I
think you have to use arrogant
underneath okay do it and key to six
over the four horses in a super okay
there you go
you the man Hank appreciate that well
will repeat that for everybody else
later on you tell Al and everyone else
we said hi okay yeah and you give my
love to Susie okay right back at you see
Hank there's hank goldberg the one and
only four more Rich Eisen show tuned to
audience channel 239 on directv or
download the Rich Eisen show app